mon cher jean pierre coffe ça ça donne
jour où ça va alors vous faites un
bouquin là qu'il est très très bien vous
aviez fait déjà potager plaisir est là
je le montre à la caméra qui vous fait
faire bonheur 1 il ya la plage on peut
tout faire comme ça maintenant non c'est
prévu c'est prévu vous appartient
on va faire les en janvier les apps
fruitiers janvier 2000 et en novembre
les mêmes en 2001 non en novembre 2000
les larbins des tablettes rue je serai
celui-là vous avez les peurs en neuf ans
mais n'ont pas besoin d'eux a dû
attendre
vous savez est ce que vous savez que
pour avoir une fleur fauve est une
graine et où il est un petit moment donc
ça pousse toi tais toi deux minutes tu
vas pas me casser mon coach par là si tu
te plais routier et et un airbus c'est
un peu long une fois vous affrontez faut
attendre que ça pousse demandé à hoëdic
city qui jardine et qu'il n'ya pas
qu'eux donc j'ai j'ai commencé ma série
arbres en 1995 mais j'ai planté pendant
tout ce temps là parce que toutes les
photos sur des photos qui sont faites
chez moi et sur des oeuvres qui
m'appartient
oui c'est tout les fleurs aussi là
toutes les fins c'est vrai il ya 150
espèces de fleurs de la longue jusqu'en
mai nathan est on si j'ai vu les débuts
du potager j'ai pas vu les débuts de du
jardin magnifique on n'ose pas marché
c'est terrible c'est bien c'est un vrai
travail donc bas et qui n'est programmé
parce que ça peut avoir trois mois de
retard mais on en principe c'est sacha
un livre pas en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui les tulipes les
quadro ce moment c'est la pleine période
des fleurs de printemps évidemment des
fritillaires de tout ce droit les
fritillaires fritillaires c'est une 2e
non compensés pour thalassa d'une beauté
extraordinaire c'est faux c'est alors il
ya la fritillaire classique
c'est une plante qui est supposé faire
fuir les taux alors on en trouve
beaucoup dans les jardins ils sont très
mauvais c'est comme un des clochers
seront versés mais la petite frite in r
je lis ravissante c'est une des choses
d'études extraordinaire qui soit c'est
une clochette dont l'extérieur à une
couleur et l'intérieur une autre et tout
ça avec des tâches encore de couleur
différente c'est du nid
beauté absolue entre et lagerfeld lui
cherchait à faire fuir les taux puis la
tire lait vieille taupe avec les filles
alors donc à part ça attendez donc à
celui qui la sort il sort la tête ar
banq et chez plon alors on vous retrouve
sur tf1 à 13h40 aussi le bonheur parce
qu'après journal de jean-pierre pernaut
il ya du monde et alors vous faites une
émission qui s'appelle bien jardiner 1
et ligne au tfc sur tf1 on peut le dire
et vous beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux que
joël robuchon qui fait cuisiner comme un
grand est ce que vous êtes déjà visuel
robuchon dans cuisiner comme un grand
chef
regardez regardez ça vous donnera des
idées de sketch mais attention à ce
qu'on lance dès maintenant et met en jeu
sa sécurité personnelle
la chose qui m'a sidéré mais en voilà
mais je vais venir à terminer jean
pierre tout par rapport à reculons
rebuchon il fait un boulot c'est le sien
et moi j'espère que je fais bien le mien
dans un programme court voilà c'est que
la vénère l'opération vous dire la
vérité ça marche
mais pas bon vous me demandez de donner
un jugement sur un homme que je respecte
parce que c'est quand même un très très
anneaux mons cuisinier c'est un homme
qui a une très belle qualité c'est un
compagnon et je respecte et compagnon du
tour de sadia particulièrement cet actif
il n'est pas il fait que lui confèrent
ses compagnons doublement aussi que les
autres de comprendre notre jardin
édition des jardins sur les a avant vous
parce que c'est un énorme succès
aujourd'hui j'ai paillat qui a eu
nicolas le jardinier michelisz tout à
fait je connais évidemment michel liste
il m'arrive de lui serrer la main quand
je le rencontre dans des expositions où
il l'est où je suis je vous signale que
michelisz elle prêchait président de la
confrérie de l'ortie dont vous avez été
décoré en pierres sèches et moi j'aime
bien vous voyez ça oui on vous dit ça
suffit
voilà ça c'est ce que c'est ça n'ont pas
dit si ça permet à la productrice des
trois relais elle me dit lâché thierry
il me dit pas chérie métier là vous
faites chier tout le monde est là patate
oui sur marque pourrait très bien donc
on va passer à la suite de l'émission